hi kevin o'leary here business and
investor entrepreneur you probably know
me from ABC shark tank I want to
personally invite you to join me in
Orlando for an exciting pharmacy
industry event unlike any other that
I'll be speaking at in February the 2016
PDS together toward tomorrow's super
conference hosted by PBS the leader in
business development for pharmacy owners
nationwide it will take place wednesday
through saturday February 24 through
27th 2016 if you own a pharmacy and if
not attend to this business growth event
before you must be there trust me it
will be transformative your business and
your quality of life however if you've
been in business for a while pds will
show you new ways to reinvent your
business achieve growth and
profitability and stave off constantly
evolving competition the annual super
conference is hosted by industry veteran
visionary dan venimos CEO of pharmacy
development services dan is well known
for predicting and forecasting future
industry trends and staying ahead of the
curve especially with technological
advancements this won't be your typical
industry event filled with boring
clinical content instead you will heal
critical information and new ways of
reinventing your business including
business skills you never learned in
pharmacy school benefits of networking
with hundreds of successful pharmacy
owners becoming a trusted healthcare
partner for your customers and remember
customers are everything moving fast and
differentiating yourself from growing
and changing competition diversifying
and finding new revenue streams for your
community they care about your business
and you care about them increasing the
profitability of your existing customer
base and implementing successful
programs already tested by dozens of pds
member case studies you will leave the
annual pds conference thinking and
acting like a bonafide entrepreneur and
in a totally different business than the
one you arrived with and being an
entrepreneur is something I know
a little bit about and I will be
personally speaking to you about it in
depth at the super conference in orlando
the team of keynote speakers myself
included and other business experts and
vendors that den has assembled for the
super conference will teach you
everything you need to know to grow and
sustain your successful business over
the long haul the independent pharmacy
industry is expanding and there is a
tremendous opportunity in this three
trillion dollar healthcare industry for
independence to play a more significant
role please join me dan and the entire
PDS team in Orlando as we move together
toward tomorrow in 2016 and seats are
going fast so you must register at PBS
conference com / register that's ww PDS
conference com / register do it today
I'll see you there